Turquía una nación con grandes
problemáticas internas que van más allá
de sanear una economía estancada y una
moneda en declive sin duda los trágicos
terremotos del pasado febrero que
dejaron más de 50.000 muertos y
golpearon al 16% de la población turca
es uno de los temas Cómo va a
reconstruir las ruinas el próximo
presidente muchos se preguntan por qué
los sismos no le pasaron factura
política reviepta y perdón quien durante
sus 20 años en la política edificó y
realizó grandes obras de infraestructura
en todo el país muchas no contaban con
la calidad de seguridad suficiente para
prevenir tragedias de esa magnitud en
los últimos años también creció un
fuerte sentimiento nacionalista en
Turquía así como los casos de violencia
contra los refugiados inmigrantes Y es
que Turquía es el país con mayor número
de refugiados sirios unos 3,7 millones
ambos candidatos cerduan y el opositor
que mal que le instalólu abogan por
enviar a estas personas de regreso a
Siria con el amparo de Damasco un país
cada vez más cercano al islamismo y
alejado del y la apertura con la quedoan
inició su carrera política los derechos
de las mujeres y personas lgbtiq más
siguen estando amenazados en 2021 erdoan
sacó al país del convenio de Estambul un
tratado internacional para condenar la
violencia intrafamiliar
como feministas y personas lgbtiq más
decimos que tenemos derecho a vivir como
queramos en este país queremos vivir
libremente con nuestra orientación
sexual y nuestras preferencias políticas
otro reto es crear las condiciones
económicas para los jóvenes
profesionales y hacer frente a la masiva
fuga de cerebros
es un país realmente hermoso pero
desgraciadamente no está dirigido de
manera correcta y está empeorando por
eso Muchos jóvenes se van al extranjero
la geopolítica y el posicionamiento del
país en las relaciones internacionales
Especialmente con Europa Estados Unidos
y los miembros de la otan marcarán la
agenda Internacional del candidato
vencedor este domingo